hi Kelly my name is Megan Jason and I  created Miss Meghan's camp kindergardens  I was a former kindergarten teacher and  when I heard the schools were going to  be closed I grabbed her my old supplies  and I knew I wanted to teach my own two  little girls I asked some friends and  neighbors if they'd be interested in  joining and they were so I created a  Facebook group and within a few short  days  it grew to over 40,000 members and it  continues to grow every day I've loved  being able to teach students all around  the world and be a support for their  parents as well it's brought so much  positivity and togetherness and this  really uncertain time and I really think  how much this whole thing is grown is a  perfect example of your hashtag home not  alone movement because obviously we are  all in this together  [Music]  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my Channel please don't  make me keep going